[Music]
welcome to beef farms in Australia today
we will learn how Australian Farmers
operate beef
Farms Farms with an area of thousands of
hectares modern Barns and strict
management
system in Australia a typical cow Farm
can span thousands of hectares each Farm
is a miniature world where people and
nature blend together Australia is one
of the most efficient cattle producers
in the world and ranks third in the
world in beef exports Australia's total
cattle herd is currently about 29.3
million heads the area serving the beef
industry accounts for over 55% of
Australian agricultural area this
industry creates jobs for about 200,000
workers throughout the chain from
livestock farming to processing and
Retail Australia exports 70% of its beef
and ve output to about 100 countries
with a turnover of 6.45 billion
USD the cows are carefully cared for by
skilled Farmers especially on farms
Farmers Only raise about 150 cows to
ensure investment in equipment
techniques and quality management with a
small scale farmers can pay attention to
the health and habits of each cow this
is also the direction of cow farming
development that countries such as
Australia America Japan are applying
[Music]
cow's Health always comes first on farms
in Australia each cow is closely
monitored by a team of professional
veterinarian they conduct regular health
checks from check temperature heart rate
and thoroughly check for Digestive and
respiratory problem in addition
veterinarians also vaccinate necessary
vaccines to prevent diseases when
detected ill if there are any unusual
signs they immediately intervene and
apply appropriate treatment measures
furthermore the Farms always maintain a
clean Airy living environment and
provide adequate nutrition enough to
ensure optimal cow Health all of this is
aimed at maintaining cow health and
productivity while ensuring product
quality when it reaches the
consumer animal care is more than just
providing food and water it's more
important to create a comfortable and
healthy living environment for cows on
Australian Farms Farmers understand that
PE swore the happiness of cows directly
affects their health and productivity to
ensure this Farms designed spacious
well-ventilated barns that are always
clean with clean water and nutritious
food but more than that they are free to
roam the green fields where they can
move freely sunbathe and enjoy the fresh
air the farm also uses high-tech
equipment to monitor the behavior and
health status status of each cow
ensuring that any signs of stress or
abnormalities are detected and treated
promptly in addition it is also
important to maintain a close
relationship between the caregiver and
the animal creating a harmonious
environment where the cow feels safe and
loved all of this not only helps cows
grow healthily but also contributes to
creating highquality milk and meat
products bringing absolute satisfaction
to
[Music]
Consumers animal care is more than just
providing food and water it's more
important to create a comfortable and
Healthy Living environment for cows on
Australian Farms Farmers understand that
PE swore the happiness of cows directly
affects their health and productivity to
ensure this Farms design spacious
well-ventilated barns that are always
clean with clean water and nutritious
food but more than that they are free to
roam the green fields where they can
move freely sunbathe and enjoy the fresh
air the farm also uses high-tech
equipment to monitor the behavior and
health status of each cow ensuring that
any signs of stress or abnormalities are
detected and treated promptly in
addition it is also important to
maintain a close relationship between
the caregiver and the animal creating a
harmonious environment where the cow
feels safe and loved all of this not
only helps cows grow healthily but also
contributes to creating highquality milk
and meat products bringing absolute
satisfaction to
Consumers the life of an Australian
farmer in cattle farming is a story of
dedication passion and love for nature
those are the days that start at dawn
when the sun is just rising and end as
dusk
Falls every day is a journey full of
challenges and joys as they take care of
each cow watching their every step of
development it is a pride and a legacy
passed down from generation to
generation hopefully through this video
you will understand more about a
profession that many people consider
their life a profession that connects
people with nature and is an integral
part of the Australian agricultural
landscape thank you for following if you
love inspiring stories about Rural Life
and want to discover more about the
world of Australian beef farming hit
subscribe and turn on the notification
Bell don't forget to like and share to
support the channel
a
[Music]